this video was made possible by hover
professionalize your web presence with a
custom email address for 10 off
at hover.com wendover
this is the two-page document that
changed
the world it's what's referred to as a
notification to the world trade
organization committee on technical
barriers to trade
a type of document that to anyone in the
know is
thoroughly mundane in fact every few
hours
another such notification enters the wto
system
each signifying that yet another country
wants to make yet another change to its
rules regarding the import or export
of goods or services this particular
notification though
submitted on july 18 2017
managed to send the entire global
recycling industry
into a tailspin or possibly even
a death spiral put simply this document
broke the world's recycling system
but here's how it worked before this
document let's say a woman
in littleton colorado has yogurt for
breakfast
the yogurt is packaged in a thin
polypropylene plastic container
and so once finished she disposes of it
into her recycling pin this is then
picked up by a recycling truck a few
days later
and brought here to the local recycling
company's materials recovery facility
there this yogurt container along with
all the rest of the single stream
recycling picked up that day
is dumped out and placed into this
semi-automated sorting system
some products are simple to isolate most
metals for example can be picked up by
magnets while paper
and cardboard can be easily sorted by
density as they're typically lighter
than other recyclables
glass plastics and non-magnetic metals
are little more difficult to sort
but each looks quite distinct so optical
scanners operate blowers or other
diversion tools
that are able to sort these out with a
few more steps the facility
is more or less left with just plastic
but that's
where things get difficult plastic comes
in all sorts of shapes
sizes and types and different shapes
sizes or types of plastic
are recycled in different ways optical
sensors start out by at least
accomplishing
a high level sort though for example in
many u.s states
plastic bottles are sold with a 5 or 10
cent deposit
meaning that recycling companies put a
lot of effort into recovering those from
the mix
as they can be sold for at least
relative to the other plastics
a lot they also put a lot of work into
recovering certain plastic types such as
high density polyethylene
as this both sells for more and is
easier to sort out the mix
since it's typically used to make larger
items like plastic crates shampoo
bottles
and other products where sturdiness
matters the polyethylene and other
higher value plastics are quite
accurately sorted and then melted down
into bulk raw plastic
which is resold to manufacturers certain
other plastics though
have a negative value they can't be sold
and in fact
it would take so much work to turn them
into usable raw material
that recycling companies would have to
pay someone to take it off their hands
typically falling into this category are
smaller items like bottle caps plastic
bags and other scraps below 3 inches or
8 centimeters in width
that just can't be easily sorted by
automated systems
these are then aggregated together and
at best
used to generate electricity through
incineration or at worst
are just sent to a landfill so to
summarize
there's high value plastic that's
recovered immediately negative value
plastic that's either incinerated or
sent to a landfill
and then there's a third category in
between those two and that's
where things get interesting anything
that isn't small and unrecoverable or
large
and valuable is typically mixed together
and formed into
big bales of unsorted medium-sized
medium value plastic
that effectively have a neutral value on
the free market
the raw materials in these bales known
as mrf residuals
is not quite valuable enough to pay for
the sorting process they would need for
recycling
which leads to their neutral value at
least
in the u.s after it takes its trip
through the materials recovery facility
that yogurt container from littleton
colorado would if properly sorted
end up in one of these mrf residual
bales
these are then loaded into the back of a
semi truck driven 1 000 miles to the
port of long beach california
there the bales are officially exported
from the u.s
loaded into a shipping container and
placed on an enormous
yet empty hong kong-bound cargo ship
now with this knowledge some might ask
a question how on earth did we end up
with this system
theoretically designed to reduce our
impact on the world
where our waste is shipped across the
world
to that there's actually a surprisingly
specific
answer decades ago in 1969
the first national conference on
packaging waste convened
and in that room were a number of
plastics industry executives
throughout that event they heard
municipal leaders from around the
country expressed their concern
about just how permanent plastic was
back then the material was becoming
cheaper and cheaper
and was quickly gaining prominence in
the packaging world but this mountain
concern
among municipal leaders itself led to
mountain concern
among plastics executives they came to
believe
that this plastic hesitancy would
quickly become
an existential threat for the industry's
growth
so plastics knew they needed a solution
they needed a way to make plastic
sustainable
the problem there wasn't one so
backup option rather than creating a
real solution
they willfully and knowingly created and
propagated a system
that didn't work but looked like a
solution
recycling from a technical standpoint
you can
sort melt down and reuse plastic thereby
reducing its impact on the world
but that's not why it doesn't work from
a social perspective
people do often do their part and at
least somewhat
separate their trash from recycling but
that's also not why
it doesn't work why recycling doesn't
work
is because overall it's not
profitable it's very simple oil is cheap
at least now and when oil is cheap
making new
plastic is cheap meanwhile sorting
transporting and melting down existing
plastic
is expensive in 2017 virgin pet
plastic cost about 54 cents per pound
while recycled pet cost about 63 cents
per pound
and was lower quality than the
alternative therefore
demand for recycled pet was low so waste
management companies
couldn't turn a profit turning used pet
into raw recycled pet
at scale when companies can't make a
profit recycling
it doesn't happen or at least not at the
rates needed to make the plastics
industry sustainable
for the plastics industry though all
they needed was the perception of
sustainability
and even though a big chunk of what went
into a recycling bin ended up
not recycled consumers and municipal
leaders were happy
because they believed that the plastic
they consumed
was guilt free that's how that yogurt
container tossed in littleton colorado
ended up on a boat to hong kong
now the rule just mentioned is still
valid
plastic is only recycled when it's
profitable but for a brief moment in
time
it was all thanks to a trifecta of
economic conditions
in china first shipping was incredibly
cheap
western nations like the us have long
had a significant trade deficit with
china
essentially america buys far more from
china
than china does from america that means
that cargo ships from greater china
travel to the u.s almost completely full
but then return with plenty of extra
capacity
meaning shipping rates to china are far
lower than shipping rates
from china thanks to that you could get
one of those mrf residual bails
across the pacific for next to nothing
in addition to this since the 1980s
china has been writing its way through
an unprecedented phase of economic
growth
this was so dramatic that the company's
industries
literally could not find enough raw
materials including plastic
to fulfill their demands therefore with
constrained supply
and high demand even recycled plastic
prices went up
giving the recyclers in the country more
room to cover
costs in addition especially in more
rural areas
wages were low in china those mrf
residual bails are composed of those
difficult to sort plastics
but humans can sort just about anything
profitably
as long as their wages are low enough
so all in all considering shipping to
china was effectively free
and raw materials were higher and wages
were low the equation
just happened to work out that in the
late 90s 2000s and early 2010s
sorting and recycling mrf residual bales
in china
was just ever so slightly profitable
that's why upon arrival to hong kong the
plastic yogurt container disposed of in
littleton
along with everything else in these
bales is immediately transferred onto a
smaller barge
and re-exported out of hong kong for a
short journey across the pearl river
delta to the guangdong province
in mainland china then after an 8 000
mile
13 000 kilometer journey to the other
side
of the world it ends up at its final
destination
the well-pine plastic industrial company
just outside
guangzhou there the bales are unloaded
spread out and low-wage workers manually
sift through the contents
eventually finding that yogurt container
and putting it in a pile
along with the rest of the polypropylene
plastics
from there the polypropylenes are melted
down purified
and reformed into pellets which then
eventually
are sold in bulk to another manufacturer
somewhere else in china
for a very very slight profit
now this whole system of taking
effectively
valueless mrf residual bails and
shipping them across the world to a
place where they did have a very slight
positive value
worked it wasn't elegant it wasn't clean
but it worked and that's how for a few
decades
the western world recycling system
functioned
the most valuable stuff was sorted and
sold domestically
the value-less stuff was exported to
where it had value in china
and the stuff with a negative value was
sent to the landfill
or incinerated but then came
that document the notification to the
world trade organization committee
on technical barriers to trade all this
said
was that china would starting at the end
of 2017
banned the imports of 24 products
covered
under these hs codes the numerical
classifications
used to simplify international trade
these particular five though
were the ones that created this big
problem for the plastics industry
they translate to waste pairings and
other scrap
of polymers of ethylene of polymers of
styrene
a polymers of vinyl chloride of
polyethylene glycol terrifylate
and other waste pairings and scraps of
plastics
effectively by banning these five hs
codes
they banned the import of almost all
plastic
waste as a result the country's 2018
plastic import volume dropped 99.1
percent
compared to 2017. this massive
global industry quite literally ended
overnight now while the true reasoning
behind
any chinese government decision is
always elusive
at least according to this document it
was that the import of these products
was creating a serious environmental and
public health
problem this is likely true
as mrf residual bails are by their very
nature
unsorted they often included hazardous
materials that could seriously harm
those sorting them
and this went on to cost the government
since the government runs much of the
country's health care system
in addition the sorting facilities in
china would often
illegally dump the portion of the
plastics that even they couldn't
profitably recover
creating an environmental problem that
the government had to pay
to clean up therefore while the private
companies that actually sorted and
processed these mrf residual bails
turned a slight profit
china as a nation was losing money
by processing the world's trash so
essentially even though it looked like
plastic recycling was profitable
once the externalities were priced in it
once again became clear
that plastic recycling was not in fact
a viable system that's why china issued
this document
that's why they ban plastic waste import
and that's
why the world's recycling system broke
nowadays when a woman in littleton
colorado throws her yoga container into
the recycling bin
the journey that ensues is often far far
shorter first as before it's picked up
by a truck brought to a materials
recovery facility
sorted down and packed into one of those
mrf residual bails
but after there are now three main
options the first is that it's exported
as before
but not to china in response to the
import ban
malaysia tripled their plastic import
volume between 2017
and 2018 becoming the largest processor
in the world
and some other nearby low-wage countries
ramped up as well
eventually though these countries will
undoubtedly realize
what china did processing mrf residual
bails
may be profitable to a company but not
to a country
the amount of health and environmental
issues it creates
in the long run costs more than the
industry
makes even despite the alternate plastic
export options
the us's export volume which includes
more than just mrf residual bails
still dropped by a third between 2017
and 2018.
there was just no one who would take
these bails
even for free since with the removal of
china from the market
very few companies could turn a profit
processing them even outside the u.s
the global value of one of these bails
went from slightly positive
to clearly negative and remember
recycling only works
when it's profitable therefore with far
fewer buyers
mrf residual bales piled up and up until
eventually
the waste processors gave up and put
them into the same category as
bottle caps scraps and those other small
unrecoverable unprofitable pieces of
plastic
now when you put something into one of
those
big blue bins that are supposed to lead
to a second life for your waste
it ends up more often than not in the
incinerator
or landfill plastic recycling with the
exception
of those few highest value items is now
definitively
broken but here's the thing it's
was always broken plastic recycling with
limited exception
never generated more money than it cost
and so it was never
economically sustainable the china
system
was just a blip thanks to a unique set
of economic circumstances
and a government that didn't yet
recognize the cost of the industry's
externalities
that puts the plastics industry back
where it was in 1969
people are starting to realize that
there is no way to make plastic
sustainable there are some half
solutions
some scientists are working to develop
an enzyme that can eat plastic in a
matter of days
and others are trying using chemical
processes to break it down into its raw
components
but the recycling problem is not a
technical one
actually performing the process of
taking what's disposed of by consumers
sorting it and melting it down into new
raw materials
is easy what's not is the economics
the recycling problem is an economic one
and you can only
solve economic issues with economics
the true solution is simple either the
cost of recycling has to come down
or the price of raw recycled plastic has
to go
up what's going to fix recycling is when
it generates more money than it costs
but making that happen will take quite
a lot if enough consumers for example
buy products that use recycled plastic
rather than a direct alternative that
uses the virgin variant
market forces will work out in a way
that eventually
when critical mass is attained what
companies lose from customers choosing
more sustainable alternatives
is more than what they lose from paying
to swap to more expensive
lower quality recycled plastic
plastics recycling as a system was never
created
to make the world a better place rather
it was created by the plastics industry
to plug a hole in their
system it was created to propagate a
false belief
that consumption could be sustainable so
the only way
to stop plastic from overwhelming our
oceans polluting our land
and making the world a worse place to
live in
is to shut the system the entire system
down so
i get a lot of emails from potential
sponsors
companies that want my business and
other professionals
i can tell you from personal experience
that the biggest red flag for me
in cold call emails is when the address
ends in gmail
icloud yahoo or another generic
provider's domain
anyone could create that email in a few
seconds so i have no idea
if the person is who they say they are
simply put
if you don't have a professional looking
email address
people won't think you're professional
whether you're running a small business
going through school or doing anything
else where you have to send and receive
emails
customizing yours with your own domain
extension is the way to go
and hover makes it incredibly easy first
you just search and find a custom domain
and they help you get a super unique one
thanks there are over 400 extensions and
then you
take that domain which you could also
use for your website and add an email
account to it
you could quite literally have a new
professional email in about two minutes
and i can personally attest to how easy
hover makes it
since they're what i've used for all my
business emails for years
making it even easier hover is offering
wendover viewers 10
off their first purchase by going to
hover.com wendover
and with their already super reasonable
prices this makes getting a custom email
a true
no brainer so to step up your email game
for 10 off
and help support this channel head over
to hover.com
wendover